[Music]
far edan it wasn't supposed to be like
this
go on Mac it's over there but if anyone
can set things right
Jule I knew it would be you
Rico feels like a game grappling with
insecurities over its length it's an
eight-hour action game in which players
along with companions called core BOTS
explore dungeons to find power-ups and
progress through the story like Metroid
Prime
it offers freeform adventuring where new
items and abilities invite players to
re-explore old areas it also attempts to
bake in the hyperactive lock on strafe
combat of Prime and for the most part it
succeeds
main character Jewell shoots colored
lasers that do more damage on matching
enemies corrupted robots mount the
assaults in big groups the crowd control
requires you to frequently cycle through
colors to best manage threats the combat
is simple but this system gives the
moment-to-moment engagement some
intricacy and dynamism most enemies are
powered by robot souls called cores and
dual can snatch these away to upgrade
the start of her own core boards the
mechanic is like reeling in a fish where
you pull at the opportune moments and
ease up when there's too much resistance
it's a thrilling moment of tension in
combat scenarios are already designed to
overwhelm the thing enemies can also net
you materials to make new pots that
bestow passive bonuses and cobots you
can have two core BOTS with her at the
same time and swap them in and out bow
they follow you around everywhere and in
battle can execute lethal attacks which
not a satisfying amount of help of the
enemy's life bulb when combined with
your own charge shots Mack the dog has a
tackle set the spider has a barrage of
rockets and Duncan the ape has a ground
pound you can call her companion back to
her side during vowels so there's also
an element of strategy to attacking and
defending for example Duncan can be left
to tear it up since he's a tank but Saif
needs to be kept out big skirmishes to
give him the range he needs to stay safe
and also to be effective tool is very
light on her feet an enemy's force you
to stay immobile with a hail of bullets
and bombs these can only be avoided with
deft leaps and bounds so like an arcade
shooter you have to find the openings in
waves of projectiles to thread yourself
between and maneuver around the
environments to get some breathing room
the combat systems aren't seamlessly
connected but they do support each other
to create a very proactive combat style
together they give you enough place to
spin to make the overall experience
chaotic and engaging
the world of Rico is barren and lacks
visual variety but there are some small
touches that spark the imagination it's
desert landscape is cut with the
remnants of a robot workforce bruised by
incomplete terraforming and scarred by
signs of battle between man and machine
dungeons are all part cave part
underground left but given a base coat
of fire ice or poison its characters are
Saturday morning cartoonish jewel is
chirpy and leaps into challenges head-on
and the core boards are equally as
vivacious Mac for example is made of
junk but here's a soul of an eager pub
his tail wags like a metronome at 200
bpm he sniffs circles box and bounds
max good I'm sorry
had it been comfortable with its brevity
Rico could have been a scrappy little
shooter but towards the end of the game
it repeatedly sends you on fetch quest
to find prismatic cause these are
enclosed in drab spheres that are
difficult to discern from all the brown
iron beams and black metal sheets that
make up Rico's world prismatic hose can
also be found in the extra arena
traversal or adventure dungeons the
gameplay in these are bare-bones
they each have unimaginative sub
objectives like finishing within a time
limit or shooting a specific number of
switches and going through them over and
over again is incredibly monotonous this
issue is worsened by Rico's loading
screens which can lost between 2 and 3
minutes sometimes the game will crash
altogether and other times it will fail
to load the map which means restarting
and more loading screens Rico's missteps
are a real shame because it can be quite
charming otherwise I wanted to like it
more and had it not overstay his welcome
I would've but in the end like it's
robots Rico is a game with a bright soul
encased in parts that I use well past
their prime
[Music]
you